this year has gone by really quickly and
it feels like a lot has happened but at
the same time it feels like not much has
changed but what has changed is that
i've read some books so hello and
welcome to the cheeky science show where
in this video i'll score the different
science books i've read this year and
provide a brief overview
so the first science book i read this
year was being mortal
illness medicine and what matters in the
end by atoll gwande
atoll was a surgeon at the brigham and
women's hospital as well as an author
and here he recounts a modern experience
of mortality what it's like to get old
and die how medicine has improved things
but also how it hasn't
this book made me feel uncomfortable at
times but was also heartwarming and
somewhat reassuring he begins by
providing an understanding of what
happens as we age beyond a pure
scientific definition but instead to a
more personal and emotional one frankly
the loss of independence
atoll then raises the obvious question
of who will then look after the elderly
while suspect is far better at
addressing the problems than finding
solutions he does go on to discuss
strategies to regain independence and
effectively this comes down to switching
boredom with spontaneity loneliness with
companionship and helplessness with
responsibility for another being
atl also argues for a wider adoption for
interpretive doctors doctors who ask
patients what they want what is most
important to them and then makes
decisions about the best treatment
options
instead of being in complete control or
giving all the control to the patients
and so given the changing demographics
this book is not only timely but
hopefully will motivate more discussions
on how we should act
and i did make a video summarising this
book and so yeah generally i would
recommend it
next up is the longevity diet by
photolongo this book describes a diet
for longevity based on what volta
describes as the pillars of longevity
this includes basic research
epidemiology studies clinical trials
centenarian studies and models of
complex systems
then discusses the fasting mimicking
diet and touches on the proposed
mechanism for how this diet is thought
to be beneficial
whilst an interesting and enjoyable read
the reason for the slightly lower score
is that a good chunk of the book
discusses the components of the diet and
other sections i found to be a little
bit repetitive
the next book i read was bad blood by
john karey rue this book is much
different to the others i've discussed
so far and by that i mean it's from more
of a journalistic perspective
bad blood is a demonstration of why i'm
shocked by how much detail the author
knows about the actual story
this is similar to the code breaker by
walter isaacson which i was going to
mention in more detail but i only got
halfway through the book before
misplacing it and i haven't finished it
yet
but what i had read was very good anyway
back to bad blood the way this book was
written i was genuinely gripped like one
day i could definitely see some netflix
drama being made on it i knew very
little about theronors and elizabeth
holmes before reading this book and now
having read the backstory of how it's
all unfolded i can't tell if it's put me
off trying to ever develop a biotech
company or whether it's provided the
perfect example of how not to run a
biotech company
if you don't know about thronos then to
cut a long still continuing story short
thoroughnose was a company that claimed
to have developed a blood test that
could diagnose for various conditions
from only a pinprick of blood these
claims have since been proven false
also i now think i understand why i got
many concerning looks when i've
described to friends and family before
my interest in personal diagnostics and
blood tests
so yeah but uh more from the point this
is a genuinely a really good book and i
highly recommend it
next i read what is life by paul nurse
this is a very short and succinct tell
to some of the core concepts in biology
for me this book covered much of what i
already know but for anyone who hasn't
done a degree in biology or wants an
easy read into the backstories of some
of the early discoveries in biology
including of course the title of how
poor nurse discovered some key
components of the cell cycle then need
to check out this book
the next book i read was factfulness by
hans rowling now i was unsure whether to
really include this book but i think if
you're a scientist you should read it
but also if you're not a scientist the
essence of what this book is trying to
convey is that you should be careful
what data you see on the internet
without fully understanding what the
data was showing in many ways this book
is optimistic it makes you realize that
many things are better than you thought
and that the negative news is always
more widespread than the celebration of
small successes if i had to criticize i
would say this book is far longer than
it needed to be but otherwise was
enjoyable
then i read ageless by andrew steele
this comes across as an unbiased
overview of the aging fields
the book is heavily researched and
written in an easy-to-understand manner
and although it provides your classic
intro to longevity it also provides the
latest knowledge regarding where we're
at in terms of therapeutic treatments i
learned some new things too which is
always good and i recently spoke with
andrew and the interview will drop
shortly then i read the science and
technology of growing young
similarly to ageless this book by sergey
yong provides a similar overview to the
aging fields this time with a stronger
look at the convergence with
technological progress
i guess the clue was in the title of the
book
cell gate also splits the book into the
near future of longevity interventions
and the far future and so if you're keen
to hear predictions for what the future
world of health will look like then
check this book out
i also spoke with the author quite
intensively about it so i suggest you
watch that video as well if you're
interested
and then lastly i read countdown by dr
shyness one a scientist based at the
mountainy medical center and one of the
world's leading reproductive
epidemiologists
as the title suggests
countdown tells the tale of fertility
counts not just spam counts and the
current one percent yearly decline but
also female fertility and ultimately how
the chemicals and lifestyles we lead
have changed human sexuality and is now
endangering fertility on a far scale
such that to quote from the book an
argument could be made that homo sapiens
already set the standard for an
endangered species
now i've only just finished reading the
book and i have to say i'm quite scared
one of the most striking statistics is
the somewhat lack of awareness and the
funding for the research
it has often commented on how the
national institutes of health dedicates
most of the funding to cancer
neurodegenerative and cardiovascular
diseases with only a small percentage
going to the national institutes on
aging but none of the funding goes to
reproductive research
you can expect in a new year more videos
from me on this topic as i feel the urge
to even enter this research field myself
to ensure that we can find ways to
enable safe and more natural
virtualization and to improve the health
of developing embryos
so frankly i'm quite proud of myself for
the books i've managed to read this year
this of course isn't every single book i
read this year as i've excluded the
fiction books but i hope to read even
more science books next year hopefully
more non-biological books too so any
book recommendations please leave them
in the comments
so with that hope you've enjoyed this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening
you